[Music]
on this Tuesday night new charges in an
international investigation the Ontario
man accused of helping people around the
world die by Suicide we ask that the
public be cautious and Vigilant of
online activities
hurricane Adalia heading for Florida
Temptations this could be a once in a
lifetime storm London's air pollution
solution what drivers of high emission
vehicles have to pay
and no star power allowed trying to
practice your way why Ontario plans to
ban celebrities and athletes from online
gambling ads
[Music]
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us there
are developments in the ongoing
investigation of a Toronto man accused
of supplying a lethal substance to
people at risk of self-harm 12 new
charges have been laid against
57-year-old Kenneth law who was first
arrested back in May accused of
counseling or aiding suicide
investigators allege law ran a number of
websites offering equipment and
substances to help people end their
lives and that he sold hundreds of
products to people in about 40 countries
Eric Sorensen reports on the complex
International investigation and a
warning his story includes discussion of
suicide
just days after appearing in court on
two counts of counseling or aiding
suicide Kenneth law has now been charged
in the deaths of 12 more Ontario
residents police say the 12 were all
young men or women aged 16 to 36. we
will not tolerate criminal actions by
those who prey on vulnerable individuals
in our communities and we will hold
those responsible accountable I expect
what we're going to find is the people
coached my son to take his own life they
encouraged him to do it Tom parfette's
son died by Suicide he believes after
buying sodium nitrite from Kenneth law
online law was a chef and lived in a
basement apartment in this Mississauga
home his case came to light after a UK
news investigation police in the UK
found that 88 people who made purchases
from law online later died the people
who are encouraging vulnerable people
like Tom
have had no consequences whatsoever pure
Regional Police put out a video warning
the public to watch out for online sales
of sodium nitrite as well as masks hoods
and other equipment that can be used to
cause self-harm police also identified
several online companies they believe
law operated we saw a real spike in
Ontario of people dying Tyler hickey
co-authored research three years ago
that showed suicides from sodium nitrite
increasing in Ontario he's concerned
about online access there seems to be uh
increased promotion of using these
substances it does create an opportunity
I think for a public health initiative
to perhaps restrict our readily
available access to these substances
late Tuesday David parfat said he's
pleased Canadian police are making
progress but wants governments to do
more to shut down online sales to make
sure anybody who is praying on the
vulnerable by using websites to
encourage them to take their own life
it's also stopped immediately more than
a hundred deaths have now been linked to
Kenneth law but the investigation is far
from over police believe law sent about
160 packages in Canada and more than
1200 packages in all to some 40
countries Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto if you or someone you know needs
help you can call talk suicide Canada
the number is
1-833-456-4566 support is available
every day 24 hours a day
preparations are in full swing Along
Florida's Gulf Coast for Hurricane
Adalia it is now rapidly intensifying
after it lashed Cuba
the outer bands of the monster storm
have already hit the Florida Keys and as
it strengthens forecasters warn of
life-threatening Storm surges tonight
and into Wednesday this is what Adalia
looks like from space State officials
say they are ready and they're bracing
for landfall on Wednesday Jennifer
Johnson reports
Italia is barreling toward Florida's
northwest coast and hurricane weary
residents are preparing for the worst
and hurricane Irma we lost our entire
house I was eight months pregnant and
came home to no house at all Florida's
governor has declared a state of
emergency in dozens of counties
idalia is expected to slam into the
Sunshine State as a category 3 hurricane
packing heavy winds and potentially
catastrophic Storm surges up to 3.5
meters if you're there in that storm
surge you're putting your life in
jeopardy Tampa's airport has already
closed businesses are boarding up
residents are stocking up on sandbags to
protect their properties idalia is
threatening Millions 11 months after
Hurricane Ian devastated the Gulf Coast
causing over 110 billion dollars in
Damages many here are still rebuilding
from that nightmare my concern right now
is will my home stand withstand the
storm search and rescue teams from other
States including New Jersey are already
on their way South we're trained we're
prepared we're ready to go at a moment's
notice local officials are preparing for
widespread power outages and water
rescues while encouraging residents to
get out and move to Higher Ground before
it's too late the one consistent
response from everyone who made the
decision to stay is that I will never do
that again so understand that mother
nature wins every time President Joe
Biden spoke with Florida's governor Ron
DeSantis a potential 2024 presidential
opponent approving federal emergency
disaster funds for the state very few
people can survive being in the path of
major storm surge and this storm will be
deadly if we don't get out of Harm's Way
and take it seriously after making
landfall in Florida a weekend idalia is
forecast to move east of Georgia now
also under a state of emergency and then
on to the Carolinas before heading out
to see early Friday
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
in the Atlantic hurricane Franklin is
barreling towards Canada's East Coast
the entire province of Nova Scotia is
now under a rainfall warning as much as
80 millimeters of rain could fall
overnight and tomorrow the intense storm
could kick up dangerous Surf and rip
currents
in Hay River Northwest Territory is a
dangerous Wildfire still looms over the
town there have been some harrowing
escapes such as Kathy mcbrien an
essential worker who had stayed back to
help
the fire came barreling towards me this
way and uh we just got out basically ran
for our lives that's how the only way I
can only way I can describe it
Thick Smoke is hampering firefighting
efforts from the sky temperatures are
near 30 degrees a heat warning is in
effect it's hotter there than in
Vancouver and there are fears hundreds
of wildfires could explode Heather
York's West on the situation in the
Northwest Territories
in the evacuated city of Yellowknife
empty streets have brought a new safety
concern as displaced Wildlife take
refuge in the capital displaced
residents some temporarily living in
Calgary wonder when they too can return
how much longer are you prepared to stay
away from your home much longer you know
this is not Yellow Knife you know it's a
big place it's nice to shop and
everything
and uh
but you just to get lost officials say
the fire that once seemed certain to
reach Yellowknife is now mercifully
being held but it will not be easy to
bring more than twenty thousand
residents back home it was a Monumental
task to get everyone out and it's going
to require a thoughtful and staged
approach to bring everyone back the
government says it's planning for
essential staff to be able to return to
the community the risk to the city
reduced but not completely gone these
fires are not likely to spread beyond
their existing boundaries as long as
conditions on the ground do not change
we came down this way a sudden shift in
the wind was all it took last Friday to
nearly take Kathy mcbrien's Hay River
Property out beachfront facing great
Slave Lake the essential worker believed
the water would keep them safe but when
the wind said the Flames racing towards
them they could only run for their lives
I really honestly my husband and I
believed in a heart and soul we lost
everything I just I couldn't understand
how our property and our homes could
survive what was coming it was it was
terrifying the Via reached their
driveway but because of firefighters
their home was ultimately saved and
Tuesday a shift in the wind sent the
fire back burning on itself a chance to
recover and regroup with more scorching
temperatures to come
Heather York's West Global News Calgary
all the wildfires in the extreme weather
have focused attention on climate change
but some people feel the need to go to
dramatic lengths to make their point at
the National Gallery in Ottawa today a
man smeared paint on a Tom Thompson
painting Thompson was a legendary artist
who loved the Wilderness and defacing
one of his Works has left a lot of
people puzzled Mackenzie gray reports
to make you hold into the Winds of
fossil fuel industry it's the latest act
in a trend of Eco vandalism this time in
ottawa's National Gallery a 108 year old
Tom Thompson piece splattered with paint
fossil fuel Industries
the culprit Caleb sudfeld of Langley BC
his group on to Ottawa informed Global
News minutes before the incident that he
was protesting a lack of a national
Wildfire fighting service if I was
unveiling on the sidewalk you wouldn't
care you wouldn't be filming me so
that's why we do this and that's why
we're going to continue to do this
tactics that have drawn condemnation
from artists I understand the passion
that people have especially as half the
country seems to be on fire at the
moment but it's uh it's not the way to
go about it from the Fall colors in
Algonquin came somber allergies like
Northern River purchased by the National
Gallery in 1915 for 500 Northern River
is an iconic landscape completed just
two years before Thompson's death Tom
Thompson and the Group of Seven did so
many beautiful paintings that are really
sort of pro-environmental people see the
beauty of of the natural pristine
landscape
Ottawa Police arresting sudfeld on
mischief charges it's worth it to wake
the public to continue to continue to
shed light on this problem
on to Ottawa has used this Playbook
before throwing paint on the prime
minister's office earlier this summer
and on the Toronto sign in Nathan
Phillips Square part of a worldwide
trend from climate protesters who've
thrown soup on a famous Van Gogh
cake at the Mona Lisa I know how hard it
is
all the museum people who care
desperately for these collections to
have something like this happen on their
watch as for the painting The National
Gallery says protective glass in front
of it saved it from any harm and after a
quick cleanup Donna it'll be back on
display soon
okay Mackenzie gray outside the National
Gallery thanks a first nation in
Saskatchewan says ground penetrating
radar has identified 93 potential
unmarked Graves at the site of a former
residential school English River started
searching the site of the former boval
Indian residential school in August of
2021 it now says it has found 79
suspected children's grave sites and 14
potential infant grave sites
we were not sure what to expect and what
we would find but we did know the
stories that were shared
over Generations about the treatment of
these students and those students who
never returned home
and from those stories we had an idea of
where to look the First Nation says it
needs to further investigate the site
and says it will keep searching
Ontario Premier Doug Ford is considering
returning land to the green belt after
some owners quietly put it up for sale
the premier's office says the owners
listed two properties for sale in Ajax
despite agreeing to use the land to
build new homes they claim they don't
have the development experience to meet
the province's housing objectives Ford
says the government is looking at all
options nearly 3 000 hectares have been
removed from the green belt for
development the province's auditor
general determined the government deal
was heavily influenced by developers who
stand to make billions
a plan to reduce pollution from vehicles
in London England has expanded an extra
5 million londoners will now be subject
to a levy to drive in the British
Capital if their cars don't need
emission standards the city isn't the
first to do this but is Redmond Shannon
reports some Canadian Mayors are
watching closely as they look to curb
emissions here too
a toxic atmosphere Over clean air a
rally against London mayor City Khan's
rollout of the ultra low emission zone
or Euless it's a daily fee of 12 pounds
50 or 21 Canadian for older more
polluting Vehicles affecting about 10
percent of drivers I have a
very good car runs super well it's 2012
and from today I have to pay 12.50 you
was first introduced for Central London
in 2019 it then expanded two years ago
to cover four million residents adding
the remaining 5 million on Tuesday this
final expansion is the most
controversial because it brings in
London's outer suburbs where residents
are far more likely to be reliant on
cars I feel sorry for people a strapped
for cash it seems a bit unfair to them
but on the other hand I can see the need
for clean air in the city for can it's
about public health more than climate
targets air pollution leads to A Whole
Health of health issues from asthma to
cancer from dementia to heart disease
disagree with what the the mayor is
doing I think people and families are
struggling with the cost of living
similar systems operate in other
European cities in Canada Montreal's
mayor is looking to make some downtown
areas traffic free or zero emissions but
Valerie plant says following London's
lead isn't currently possible as we're
pushing for measures for example like
the one in London we're also pushing for
more public transport options it is
absolutely crucial if we want to do this
the switch
there may be another Euless effect
outside of London too some of Khan's
colleagues in the opposition labor party
fear Euless could repel the
all-important suburban swing voters come
the next British general election
Redmond Shannon Global News London
housing crisis on Canadian campuses
coming up by some people say the influx
of international students is making it
worse
never before has Canada had so many
International students enrolling at
universities here nine hundred thousand
are expected this year they pay much
higher tuition than domestic students
sometimes as much as nine times more and
universities depend on that cash it
amounted to nine billion dollars last
year but that rise has not been matched
by an increase in housing and now one
knows that better than students trying
to find a place to live David Akin
reports
my name is Jason Leeton D'Souza for this
international student from India I feel
it's very difficult at this point to
find a house in a very short span of
time in terms of housing or these
students from Canada my brother wanted
to go this year couldn't get into
residence had to defer so I think
there's absolutely issues for sure
there's no avoiding the housing crisis
to fix it some think Canada should
reduce the number of international
students it accepts every year and while
Canada's colleges and universities
increasingly rely on the high tuition
fees those students pay in order to
replace declining Public Funding they
reject the idea of focusing exclusively
on International students I think it's a
little unfair I think it's very unfair
to to suggest that it's the
international students is is the cause
of the issue cause of the issue is a lot
of other things including you know High
inflation rates low Supply the
opposition conservatives say foreign
student visas should be tied to
available housing we will fix what
Trudeau broke and the international
student program
to ensure that when students arrive they
have homes
jobs
health care business school Professor
Mike Moffett briefed prime minister
Justin Trudeau and his ministers at the
recent cabinet Retreat and moffatt says
the Trudeau government could help build
more student housing today by
resurrecting a Harper era 2009 program
there was a funding model where
basically the federal government put
some money in a pot the provinces match
the higher the college or university put
in some money there's no reason they
couldn't do something like that again
and in fact many universities say that
15-year-old Stephen Harper era program
that would be a great solution that they
have approved shovel ready projects to
build more student housing they just
need a little Federal cash Donna okay
David Aiken in Ottawa thanks
still had what doctors in Australia
discovered and removed from a woman's
brain
[Music]
meta the parent company of Facebook and
Instagram says it has disrupted a
campaign to covertly boost China's image
on its platforms meta says it removed
over 7 000 Facebook accounts and
hundreds of other Pages groups and
Instagram accounts that pushed pro-china
narratives online it says the accounts
praised China and its policies
criticized the U.S and Western foreign
policy and individuals including
journalists Mata calls it the most
prolific covert influence operation
known to exist in the world today but
says it was largely unsuccessful
there's a strange story out of Australia
a worm living inside a woman's brain was
removed in a world's first the parasitic
worm was eight centimeters long it was
causing the 64 year old health issues
from stomach pain to night sweats and
forgetfulness even depression it was
discovered when she had an MRI doctors
say it was likely there for two months
and the worm was still alive when it was
sent away for testing
out of luck next why Ontario is Banning
athletes and celebrities from online
gambling ads
[Music]
Ontario plans to ban athletes and
celebrities from online gambling ads you
see them everywhere now and as Mike
Armstrong explains the province says
having famous people on the front
benches for betting companies may be
having an effect on children and problem
gamblers
with every tap
the legend is born
it may be one aspect of internet
gambling experts didn't see comic
basically as soon as betting online was
legalized from the great one game time
occasionally great actors advertising
floodgates blew wide open
I got nothing for you I grew up as
a kid watching Hockey Night in Canada
and had become gambling Night in Canada
and it's not just you know singling out
hockey in Canada it seems to be in all
sports download the app now well
Ontario's gaming commission is stepping
in as of February 24th of next year just
about anyone with a public profile won't
be allowed in commercials for eye gaming
companies registered in the province
that's 46 companies and their
subsidiaries that won't be able to use
entertainers social media influencers or
athletes active or retired
trying to practice your way you need it
well we're very pleased this addiction
and gambling expert says seeing
celebrities pushing online betting is
dangerous for children particularly boys
the ban is something the group had
argued for when the commission studied
the issue this spring calls to its
gambling helpline have exploded with
people needing help with online betting
it went from being around 10 15 of the
total number of calls to now the number
one reason people call the helpline what
they've prohibited starting next
February it's really broad now this
lawyer predicts Court challenges some
companies or athletes could argue the
ban limits freedom of expression there
may also be legal wrangling for athletes
like Austin Matthews who have deals and
may want to keep them there may also be
litigation between athletes and
celebrities in the company saying well
I'm still owing my money it's not my
fault which will be fascinating to watch
and I will be watching something had to
be done in my opinion and I think this
is the first step and I think it's a
good step
game there is one sort of gambling ad
the commission will still allow athletes
to do that's that way bud it says they
can promote reasonable betting and help
for addiction like Armstrong Global News
and that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm Donna freeze and tonight's
Euro Canada is bayfin in Killarney
Provincial Park Ontario thanks for
watching bye-bye
[Music]